it's uh Thursday of our Boswell sign up
early we did a business meeting did a
hypebeast and BuzzFeed an article then I
did the Vintage strange Meetup for an
hour and a half did a podcast props and
drops got to do uh a little podcast
fireside chat with the mayor and then
we're gonna go run and do a defense
activations and come back here so it's
been a it's been busy
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
foreign
what's up everybody hope everybody's
super well having a great week love you
love you love you tell Jeremy all nice
things bye
how are you here I see a great rest
[Music]
awesome thank you sorry bye well Gary it
is such a pleasure to be here with you
today here at Art basil thank you so
much for your time happy to be here
thanks for having me how does fashion
play into the V friends ecosystem and
what you're continuing to build out over
time fashion like music and Sport and
religion
and a couple of other things is like one
of the most foundational human
experiences I would argue that the
singular reason I knew nfts will play
out long term is because fashion and art
100 we we communicate through the things
we buy
so fashion specifically has been
probably the place I've been most
aggressive the defense is 18 months old
Reebok starter Kim shui right carrots I
have a very good sense of what I'm up to
I desperately want the world to fall in
love with a countable ant because I
think accountability if you fall in love
with it before you're 18 will lead to
less anxiety and depression then I start
thinking about what brand like why
forthright I struggled with Candor my
whole life I'm doing a very cool
collaboration right now with a very cool
brand and it's the fourth right flamingo
so cool you could see vintage frames and
it's [__] rad and it's fresh and I'm
gonna rock it and you can see the
friends that I've got glasses garyvee
that's cool to me because I'm an
entrepreneur five fine but over time
it's like it's the fourth right flamingo
it's the fourth right flamingo and it's
like wait a minute like it's being
forthright a good thing oh wow it is
actually if you keep it in balance and
you deliver it with kindness and so like
there are millions of people around the
world like myself who have struggled
with Candor which has led to the things
that have made them unhappy and if I can
story tell through collaborations
through you know sneaker deals and and
glasses or more directly children's
books movies televisions streaming
services toys with QR codes that let you
watch a four minute video well then over
time for the back half of my life the
next 47 years of my life I think I can
leave a really meaningful impact and so
I think very vigorously about every
collaboration why what how and now here
we are Gary I want to thank you so much
thank you brother appreciate it cheers
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
fashion really yeah this started before
starter this started before Kim shui
um but according to vintage frames team
like really took it seriously the most
luxurious Flamingo on the planet
unbelievable
unbelievable love it I'm like very like
creative is subjective and like but they
were like really really working to get
it to where they wanted to and then it
got to a point where we're like oh we
could do a new sort of thing at Basel
because of the timing and so like every
time I'm in the moment when it's
something that was thought of nine
months ago it feels like another
accomplished brick in the house that
we're gonna build between 40 and 55
years so it feels good
[Music]
because you know the brain boosting
benefits of blueberries I do I was
wondering if I could throw one and see
if you can catch it let's go let's go
that's very important this is very
important to me first try first try
it's good it's good you know how upset I
am we got we got two guys for days that
was a pretty good feed though I lost it
was a great beat I lost it in the light
yeah Jersey blueberry
[Applause]
it makes it so much worse is this the
fifth one yeah
well that was a bad one that was short
let's keep going
I'm not happy about it seven [__]
times if you could get one piece of
advice as far as a step in the right
direction for people that are ready to
stop working and get into
entrepreneurship where do you start you
start by first being self-aware a lot of
people actually aren't going to be good
at entrepreneurship
they just might need a job that they
like more almost nobody likes their job
the stunning majority are dislike or at
best neutral about it they're not on
fire they're not waking up on Monday
like let's [__] go and so to me
LinkedIn no different than you listening
to One Piece of content for me that
changed the course for you because you
figured out this for somebody right now
who's watching this if they realize that
they can post things about their
opinions their observations and their
expertise about what they do for a
living if you're a five-year lawyer and
you say something I'm seeing in law
around IP law and you write four
sentences you make a video it depends on
how you communicate written word or
video one piece of content on LinkedIn
where you have no followers right now
can change the course of your life
because now you have inbound people
offering you jobs instead of you sitting
and dwelling about hating your job and
after six months to a year there's a
piece of content that's going to come
out that's going to lead to the next job
opportunity that's what I think people
should do
there it is
oh for real
[Music]
so you're scheduled for us huh my
schedule is not how do you do it
gratitude
when you have gratitude you have
unlimited energy yeah you're just
thankful all the time well you know what
I you you speak from sense of the heart
and and you always wonder you know is
that guy real yeah of course people
always wonder thank you thank you
brother
[Music]
do you think that you still need to tie
a physical item to an nft as the market
dipped and people are looking for a
little more value in Ft that you you get
access or you get an additional benefit
do you think that'll be the thing that
kind of like brings it back upward or I
think that was the thing that made it
interesting in the first place the smart
contract and the fact that it could
enable me triggering things at any time
forever yeah was the punch line if you
kind of go into late 2020 early 2021
yeah that was the combo yeah by the
summer the money was rolling yeah and
everybody that was getting in was like I
don't even do anything I'm just gonna
sell digital assets right yeah hence
that's why we that it created the bubble
yeah so for me it was always the punch
line and to answer your question yes I
think the best operators yeah that
understand how to take advantage of the
technology that creates affirmation who
owns the flamingo they get that like
yeah that's the point yeah so thank you
so much thank you best of luck thank you
pleasure love you all right let's get
out of here
props and drops here live at Art Basel
in Miami uh there's probably some noise
in the background because there's an
event going on here at scope Beach we
have a phenomenal guest who's got some
fire kicks I just realized and then we
got the culprits that were always are
here we got kalish the brains and Herm
The Charisma
all right do you consider yourself
one I could I could draw a mean giraffe
I'm gonna do that amazing Dragon it's
happy draft but yeah I'm an artist what
about you are you an artist yeah I'm one
of the great artists of all time I need
not only my wildly commercially
successful most people have not sold
millions of dollars of art at Christie's
Auction but all jokes aside because I'm
I'm gabbing here a little and having fun
with my boys I actually have always
thought about entrepreneurship pure
entrepreneurship much closer to Art than
business
I mean back to what you were referencing
for me I've always been drawing Outside
the Lines everything was always
Innovation everything was artistically
communicating artistically ideating
seeing needs that the world hadn't seen
yet like I actually like weirdly
visualize it I'm like I'm gonna launch
this website and we're gonna sell wine
yeah it really is for me like that I
spend most of my time thinking even when
I'm in I'm thinking right now about [__]
like how I'm gonna beat her in a fight
are you going to um buy in the auditor
no why not I don't like to talk about
things I don't know about and I don't
like to buy things I don't know about I
have started my physical art Journey it
started with the nft journey it started
with that Warhol I bought right after
the befriends went off on the Christie's
thing you know like I'm like starting to
like starting to get into it but I want
to I like buying [__] because I like it
yeah and so I gotta go through my
process uh so I'm not ready but do I
feel like the way I'm pacing that I
could go really Hamp next year and truth
be told like I gotta get educated on
what's here it's like a sports card show
I know which shows have nothing good and
which ones do I'm curious so I think
I feel like I'm on my journey next year
will probably be the year where I really
like look and learn the basil part of it
and the sex and the 24 3 24 is likely my
year all right I gotta go through this
panel that's great guys great stuff
thanks for having me we love you
[Music]
[Applause]
such a pleasure I'm great brother you
ready for this it's too blessed to be
stressed let's go 100.
it's uh Thursday of our Bonzo Santa
parolee we did a business meeting did a
hike beast and BuzzFeed an article that
I did the Vintage training speed up for
an hour and a half get a podcast proper
drops about to do a little podcast
fireside chat with the mayor and then
we're gonna go run and do a befriend
activations and come back here so it's
been uh it's been busy
the reason I'm 24 7 365 is because the
greatest narcotic in the world is
gratitude if you are actually actually
not you say it because it's [__]
trending
because if you are actually running on
actual gratitude the Energy's off the
charts and I'll tell you one more thing
there this is a big one for everyone
almost everything that's not working for
everyone looking at right now isn't 100
predicated on them valuing other
people's opinions strangers their mom
their brother someone they look up to a
boss it's a major problem they're just
valuing other people's opinions so much
that it's dictating their behavior so
much and it's over before they start it
the reason I'm always innovating is
because I'm not scared to lose in front
of all of you
I am not scared to lose in front of all
of you when people here today you pitch
your business idea and somebody says I
don't like it they're not being mean
they're not a piece of [__] they don't
want your idea no I don't remember
anybody liking any of the [__] that most
worked out for me you need to be within
yourself and deploy kindness to others
nobody who's judging you is a reflection
on you you you need to fall in love with
yourself first everything else figures
itself out that's what I want for you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
what's up that video that did really
well is that that late night one a
couple days ago do you think it was
because it was late
no because last nights didn't do
anything like it's just like it's funny
because it was an older one that won
before and then we just posted one that
a few seconds ago like that was the same
and it's like doing uh atrocious
um which is [__] amazing and
fascinating like Instagram is going
through a reset right now no question so
it's like super fun to like play the
game yeah
and you're like this is not doing very
well that's so interesting for me I'm
like oh he like he's happy to learn
about my text my text two minutes ago
was how fun is it to lose
what
oh yeah like I just feel like you like
the learning yeah like what like Who's
Gonna Roll Up at me like oh we only got
39 000 views on this instead of 700 000
like my okay and not just because I've
already made it that's how it was when I
when my 19th episode of Wine Library TV
didn't do anything and got 86 views I'm
like like what and how does it feel to
look back now
um
I'm indifferent yeah the cheering and
the booing is the same
[Music]
welcome everyone to our be friends
Insider event we're going to dig into
characters which is gonna be super fun
but you guys are here today to co-create
with Gary which is one of the best
things about this nft world we're going
to talk about how you can see the
characters and help you draw your own so
with that Gary let's first talk about
the importance of characters and
storytelling and how it's about making
people feel
so we're about to go serious here you're
about to create a character a mascot I
like genuinely believe one of you is
gonna do something right now they have
no [__] idea you're about to do and
something insane is gonna happen the
next 20 years I'm so pumped for today's
event you can't imagine it's gonna be
like all right go and you're gonna be
like what the like you know try to think
about some [__] that you've been
thinking about the reason be friends is
going to work is I really care about it
like I think about accountable ant every
day I'm like one day I'm going to Teach
the World to be accountable and
everybody will be happy when you get to
the part that what we're here for give
it a second and maybe even start now
like what have you been thinking about
what has been true to you what have you
given a real [__] about forever it will
matter so much more than trying to come
up with something clever I can tell you
my problems meditating my silence but I
keep putting my opinion rotating my
stylist feeling like singing I know used
to be
[Music]
I know
I don't really have like a family so
I've never had anybody
it gives me anything
and you know so um
[Music]
the second thing
and I know how fulfilling it is to like
bring your team along with your Victory
to me when when my companies are winning
I'm more happy of what it means for our
ability to give raises and title things
and put them on and their opportunities
are going to come after and I uh I think
that will work for you
well I'll get a Sharpie
I love you brother
thank you so much you're welcome my man
give yourself a year
I love you brother
[Music]
foreign
you know fighting cancer fights through
it and how she works there she's she
leads up
nobody expects high-end art like this
from kids only because they're not
paying attention exactly because they're
not paying attention it's amazing like I
love that piece
we're thankful to be here I'm so
grateful amazing experience
I'm a faith father father of a basement
there three times
so for 15 years
um
what's your name Sir Marcus Marcus such
a pleasure my pleasure thanks for doing
this yeah
it's a real pleasure to meet you thank
you a lot of love
we're helping them
raise money through social media now
Tick Tock is the number one channel that
gets them money they didn't even
consider to be on tick tock
[Music]
but I loved your advice today stop
[__] listening to people's opinions
It's really hurting people thank you
yeah it is it really makes me sad
because it's like
because there's only two opinions right
there's only light and dark right and so
but most people over focus on the dark
and and the world's realized how to
weaponize fear at scale and like all the
way to the mundane of like parents the
way they parent is almost completely
predicated on fear don't do this this
will happen if you do that so it's like
if you can get people into a place of
like relying more on their own Intuition
or just like being a little more insular
it's very clear to me at this point as
someone who's on the receiving end of so
much information that that's the
punchline and like how to popularize and
make people understand there's truth in
it how do you get people to practice it
how do you get more champions of it
those are the things I think about
[Music]
I struggle with understanding why it
would ever be not appropriate to be a
nice person I just don't understand the
scenario
that lends itself for you being unkind
to someone
I just I really don't like I'm you know
I'm an entrepreneur back to the comment
you made I'm high energy I'm passionate
I like being competitive I love I love
those things but I don't think those
things compromise being kind being
empathetic being compassionate you know
I don't I don't ever
see a scenario where
the right move in this situation is to
be mean to that person I don't
understand that logic and see it in your
work when something stressful happens or
something bad happens that's a time
where a leader needs to take on the
pressure and make it better for everyone
not start making everybody feel scared
and bad and so you know to answer your
question I don't understand the logic of
negativity and thus I don't deploy it
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]